[Musique]
l'année dernière c'est pas si vous vous
souvenez
non ça c'est fait paramétrage de la
caméra à la balle et on va y arriver
mais c'est bon ça va
en fait vous êtes pas demandé comment
vous allez bien j'espère ça se passe
bien pour vous ouais le confinement le
travail tout sera la famille j'espère
simplement en bas en commentaire moi ça
va pas trop mal
et justement aujourd'hui je vous parle
de ce smartphone là vous l'avez vu dans
le titre c'est le nouveau samsung galaxy
à 21 aces nouveau patent nouveau que ça
mais quand même un peu nouveau en fait
l'année dernière je passe si vous en
souvenez je vous avais parlé du nouveau
smartphone de samsung dédiée plutôt
drôle entre et milieu de gamme
l'entrée du milieu de gamme c'était le
samsung galaxy à 20 e et le à 20 e
je n'ai pas trop aimé et là on à son
successeur c'est le à 21 aces alors il
n'ya plus le il ya le s et seront sais
pas pourquoi mais en tout cas c'est lui
est alors cela m'intéresse
on a regardé s'il intéressant on va
regarder s'il est fait pour vous et
surtout on va voir s'il est bien
positionné par rapport à la concurrence
parce que c'était vraiment le point que
j'avais relevé l'année dernière par
rapport au samsung galaxy à 20 e
donc on va regarder ce à 21 ans est ce
pour vous dire c'est au final c'est un
smartphone qui est intéressant c'est un
smartphone qu'il faut vraiment situer
par rapport à son prix et son prix vous
en douterez j'ai noté sur ma feuille de
prise de notes
il compte en tarif de base 239 euros on
peut trouver un petit peu moins cher
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse vous amis
tous les liens en bas dans la
description 239 euros quasiment 240
euros il ya beaucoup de monde sur le
marché dans cette gamme de tarifs là on
va regarder quelles sont ses
spécificités on va regarder s'il
intéressant surtout on va voir s'il est
fait pour vous mais avant toute chose si
ce n'est pas déjà fait j'habite à venir
vous abonner pour tout savoir sur la
tête de voter les smartphones sont tous
les usages vous connaissez l'histoire
vous avez le petit bouton rouge qui est
situé juste ici vous cliquez dessus et
vous un questionnaire la cloche pour
identifier et qu une prochaine vidéo
rivera et ça c'est vachement bien
bacci pas de la blague si on va pas
avoir le smartphone avec la plus belle
finition signé samsung la boîte déjà on
est dans le même système d'ouverture que
l'année dernière si tu veux bien mon
petit lapin mais c'est efficace une fois
de plus on est à 240 euros
vous avez vos petits écouteurs de quoi
venir le recharger bon c'est un grand
classique ça marchera très bien le
smartphone haut lieu écoutez plutôt cool
on va retrouver un petit dos plastique
qui prend quelques traces de doigts mais
une fois de plus c'est normal on a des
reflets rck ans y est ça j'aime bien ça
très cool les reflets arc-en-ciel
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
déverrouiller très facilement votre
smartphone oui vous avez un module avec
quatre capteurs photo on se détaillera
dans quelques instants
on a une recharge en usb c'est ça c'est
cool un petit haut parleur mono un micro
une prise jack ça c'est sympathique le
bouton pour venir l'allumer et
l'éteindre le bouton de volume de
l'autre côté vous et votre tiroir de
cartes c'est me sidhoum et nano symplus
quatre micro sd on en parle en quelques
instants et sur le dessus et bien vous
avez le micro pour la réduction de bruit
voyez un grand classique vous posez
votre doigt derrière pâques ça
déverrouille très rapidement alors ici
regardez votre écran vous avez un écran
infiniti au au pourquoi parce qu'ici
vous avez votre petit trou votre petit
point sont tout ce que vous voulez
infiniti haut de 6 5 pouces est quand
même un très grand écran avec une
résolution hd plus ici pas de full hd
1600 par 720 pixels
bon c'est pas complètement dingue et pas
très surprenant dans cette gamme de prix
maintenant il ya plus si vous toujours
jeter un petit coup d'oeil à la
concurrence pour voir qu'on peut trouver
à ce prix là je vous laisse faire vos
petites recherches par vous m
en tout cas ici vous avez un écran lcd
ici c'est du tft c'est la même techno
qu'on avait l'année dernière dans le 20e
en tout cas j'aime bien par contre qui a
été corrigé cette année borg vous avez
en bas et moins proéminent que ce qu'on
avait sur le à 20 c'est beaucoup plus
joli
lorsque j'ai ouvert mon smartphone que
j'ai commencé à bosser dessus j'ai
regardé l'écran et j'ai fait ou la la la
lalala d'aller mal calibré c'est pas ouf
les couleurs au niveau des icônes
regardez-la mois notamment sur l'icône
spotify est ce que se dit oulala c'est
pas terrible
et puis j'ai fait une mise à jour et
cette mise à jour est bien le change les
choses et ça c'est bien
et bien vu de la part de samsung parce
que n'a pas révolutionné on est sur du
tft on n'est pas sur un tout qui est
complètement dingue on parle pas ici de
super amoled
non on est bien sûr lcd tft néanmoins et
bien la mise à jour elle vient apporter
vraiment ces corrections qui sont
importantes mais qui permet de mieux
calibrer qu'on n'a pas un truc et où
film mais ça marche ça marche à tous
beaucoup mieux et ça j'ai eu chaud
vous vous en douterez six mois je reçois
un smartphone qui mal calibré je vais
vous le dire et tout ça le fera pas et
bien là par contre cette mise à jour on
l'a vraiment fait son taf j'avais
vraiment peur dès le départ je me suis
dit mon dieu qu'est ce que c'est et au
final très bien très bon camp actif donc
si vous achetez ce smartphone commencé
par faire la mise à jour on est sûrs aux
smartphones dans l'entrée du milieu de
gamme vient pas non plus faire des
miracles
la partie audio est pas non plus
complètement dingue vous avez un haut
parleur mono si vous le mettez à fond il
va avoir tendance à saturer
mais rassurez vous ça je voulais dit
vous avez effectivement de petites
prises jack
donc ça c'est bien qu'il va venir
augmenter l'expérience et si vous le
souhaitez si vous en avez un point bien
branché un casque sans fil grâce au
bluetooth 5.0 côté performances on a un
processeur oak d'accord on ne sait pas
exactement lequel parce que samsung ne
communique absolument pas dessus on a
par contre ici 3 giga de ram et
uniquement 32 gigas de stockage s'est
pas beaucoup ça 32 gigas de stockage ça
vous laisse à peine 19,5 de disponible
pour vos différentes applications alors
heureusement pour les monter grâce à une
carte micro sd jusqu'à 512 mais au-delà
de ça voilà sauf que c'est aujourd'hui
un petit peu limite mais là où ce
smartphone est un champion incontesté
c'est sur la partie autonomie avec une
grosse batterie de 5000 millan perreur
vous allez donc pouvoir regarder très
très très très longtemps pour venir
jouer à tout vosges en diable est allé
sur vos différents réseaux sociaux
regarder des films des séries vous faire
plaisir maintenant le seul point négatif
c'est que vous avez uniquement de la
charge 15 watts et va donc falloir vous
armer de patience pour recharger votre
batterie de 5000 militants perreur
l'expérience logiciel est bien mieux
réussi que ce qu'on avait un vent
tourner et six sur one
ils deux basés sur l'android dit ça
marche bien très bien c'est vraiment
très très très agréable d'utilisation
vous retrouvez tous vos paramètres très
rapidement c'est intuitif c'est bien ça
mange bien on aura moins d'options que
si vous aviez un smartphone plus haut de
gamme de chez samsung
néanmoins pour me régler pas mal de
choses et notamment avoir un thème
sombre et bien vous avez vraiment ce
qu'il vous faut
comme je le disais l'arrière vous n'êtes
pas moins de quatre capteurs le tout
premier capteur ou ici et bien c'est un
capteur de 2 mégapixels couvre f2 points
4 pour le mode portrait vous avez en
dessous votre grand temps 48 mégapixels
touvre f 2.0 avec un champ de vision de
80 degrés en dessous juste là votre
ultra-grand-angle 8 mégapixels f 2.2
avec un champ de vision de 123 degrés et
pour finir ici et bien vous avez 1 2
mégapixels tour f 2.4 qui est là pour le
mode portrait pour les faits
bocquet tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.2 c'est une combinaison qui est un
peu standard samsung s'inscrit dans
l'air du temps sur ce qu'on trouve
vraiment en 2020 avec quatre capteurs à
l'arrière attention ici vous allez pas
tout faire je donc le résultat dans
quelques instants vous aurez de la
polyvalence mais une fois de plus on est
un peu moins de 240 euros donc on s'en
doute ce smartphone ne fera pas tous
très bien
vous pourrez faire quelques souvenirs
mais bon voilà au delà de ça je vous
laisse juger par vous même petite
précision à connaître si vous aimez les
zooms qui zoome et qui vont chercher
loin et si on a un zoom numérique x 8
n'y a pas de tels objectifs
c'est pas la peine de chercher trop loin
et vous pourrez faire des vidéos en full
hd en 30 images par seconde rien de bien
dingo là dessus non plus ce n'est pas un
smartphone qu'on va utiliser pour aller
faire de la vidéo on s'en doute les
photos prises sans capteur principal
fonctionne plutôt pas mal la gestion de
la lumière est assez correcte les
couleurs sont là mais c'est pas
extrêmement saturé l' ultra grand-angle
est un peu plus palau un peu moins
saturé surtout déformant on le voit bien
ici là au niveau des bâtiments
bon il est pas vraiment de correction
logicielle là dessus c'est un petit peu
dommage on continue avec le zoom x 2 ça
ira très bien ça fera le taf mais ça
commence quand même à lisser et on le
voit notamment ici au niveau des briques
ça se remarque tout de suite
et dès qu'on arrive enfin huit voiliers
on oublie il a plus de mal par contrat à
gérer les contre-jours on a beaucoup
plus de bruit la qualité pas
extraordinaire
il nous faut vraiment de la lumière et
on le voit ici là une fois de plus avec
ce contre jour ici c'est déformant c'est
pas ouf ça c'est un petit pas oublié sur
le foie de lorgner sur le x huit on met
sur la caméra principale secousse est
pas extrêmement saturé parce que si
sur l'ultra grand temps vous êtes tout
de suite oui quelles couleurs sont quand
même un peu plus cela assez surprenant
le x 2 reste un peu pâlot et le x 8 bond
oublie complètement moins accro je suis
jamais vraiment très très fan c'est
assez rare et une fois de plus c'est
confirmé ici on a du mal à trouver la
bonne distance pour prendre des photos
de maquereau qui est un intérêt pour moi
il ya très peu d'intérêt la caméra de
celle fera le boulot mais il n'y a rien
d'exceptionnel non plus là dessus quand
au mode portrait il vient des tours et
mais on manque quand même de précision
l'aï s'il a un peu de mal mais une fois
de plus ce n'est pas normal parce que la
scène est un peu plus complexe
on a ici un smartphone qui a dû à 9 c
qui n'a bien évidemment pas de 5 g et
qui n'est pas non plus étanche en tout
cas qu'il n'ya pas certification ip67 ou
ip 68 mais une fois de plus dans ce
segment de prix et dans cette gamme ça
me paraît normal
alors est-ce que ce smartphone est
intéressant écoutez moi ce smartphone il
a quand même de bien meilleurs atouts
que ce qu'on avait les dernières avec le
à 20 e que je trouvais pas terrible je
trouve que le à 21 aces et un cran au
dessus est plus intéressant et actuel
maintenant le le gros problème qui
risque de rencontrer bien c'est la
concurrence parce qu'en face vous avez
quand même de gros constructeurs un peu
énervé qui met les moyens
on aurait eu ce smartphone peut être en
dessous des 200 euros il aurait été
probablement dans la course
aujourd'hui à 239 euros je ne sais pas
si c'est le bon positionnement
d'ailleurs dites le moi vous embarquent
commentaires dites moi ce que vous en
pensez
moi je trouve pas mal je trouve beaucoup
mieux que son prédécesseur maintenant ce
que ça suffira pour ce soit un
smartphone qui se vendent beaucoup et
qui suscite vraiment l'intérêt chez
samsung
je ne sais pas à vous de nous dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouvez ce nouveau
samsung galaxy à 21 s intéressant par
intéressant est ce que vous aviez eu le
à 20 noeuds et est ce que ce à 20 s
pourrait vous tentez si vous avez lu à
20 une changeait pas s'il vous fait de
l'oeil ce un smartphone qui est plutôt
bien qu'il y sera pas exceptionnelle
mais une fois de plus à 239 euros
et d'ailleurs il ya metal black friday
qui sera peut-être l'occasion pour
trouver un tarif plus alléchants et à ce
moment-là peut-être devra-t-il
extrêmement intéressant parce que vous
en pensez bien évidemment en bas quand
un autre ou très rapidement pour
continuer à parler de tête et d'ici là
où on beaucoup d'amour des gros bisou
pour les soyez vous et à très vite
ciao
[Musique]
quand m